bienvenue à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ici à la maison de la poésie de saint
quentin en yvelines pour ce nouveau
numéro de paris saclay tv tout de suite
le sommaire avant de rencontrer le
directeur de cette maison de la poésie
nous allons vous présenter l'un des cinq
secteurs phares du cluster paris saclay
après la santé place à l'énergie
l'énergie nucléaire solaire électrique
le saviez vous 2015 c'est l'année
internationale de la lumière
l'occasion de célébrer avec faste les 50
ans de la faculté des sciences et les 60
ans du campus d'orsay avec un spectacle
son et lumière nous y étions nous
reviendrons aussi sur la journée
entrepreneuriat étudiant
c'était la cinquième édition le succès
est croissant pourquoi nous allons vous
expliquer et enfin notre agenda tous les
événements à ne pas rater en ce mois de
mars ce sera à la fin de cette émission
paris saclay et tv c'est toute
l'actualité de votre territoire mais
c'est aussi une volonté celle de vous
présenter les principaux secteurs du
cluster paris saclay
aujourd'hui coup de projecteur sur le
domaine de l'énergie 31 établissements
17 mille salariés des leaders
industriels mais aussi un tissu de pme
paris saclay a toujours une place
stratégique dans ce domaine ça continue
regardez
il existe aujourd'hui autour du plateau
de saclay déjà un écosystème extrêmement
pertinent et fort d'industriels et
petites moyennes entreprises
positionnées sur la thématique de la
gestion énergétique intelligente et nous
avons formé dans ce cadre là un cluster
dont l'objectif est de progressivement
travailler avec l'établissement
d'aménagement du plateau de saclay le
pps pour fédérer une démarche efficacité
énergétique réseaux électriques
intelligents autour des infrastructures
du plateau de saclay donc on peut déjà
citer un certain nombre d'initiatives
très intéressantes dont notamment par
exemple avec le groupe bouygues
l'installation d'une très grande
centrale solaire au tour du challenger
en lien avec le plateau de saclay et
avec l'introduction d'un certain nombre
de véhicules électriques dans le cadre
d'un micro réseau autour du challenger
on peut citer aussi autour de l'institut
de recherche technologique system x une
plateforme big data smart energy pour la
ville qui vient d'être lancé avec un
certain nombre d'acteurs industriels et
de petites start-up qui porte notamment
sur le pilotage intelligent de la charge
du véhicule électrique dont vous voyez
ici par exemple un véhicule électrique
alstom connecter avec une borne de
charge gîte ou mobility qui sont deux
acteurs présents dans cette danse est
plate forme de liberté systemx et on
continue dans cette direction
par exemple avec le support au montage
d'un projet qui s'appelle live grid qui
m on va dire la conceptualisations d'une
démarche collaborative entre les
différents établissements de
l'université paris saclay pour partager
des informations en lien avec la
consommation énergétique sur ces sites
et faire émerger de la recherche en lien
avec les différents chercheurs
positionner dans des établissements
comme polytechnique centrale supélec ou
le cea et cette initiative est piloté
par edf
qui est en train de de se repositionner
très fortement d'un point de vue r&d
dans le cadre de ce cluster énergies
autour du plateau de saclay donc c'est
une démarche en cours extrêmement
dynamique et qu'on souhaite
progressivement construire et on espère
que d'ici 2020 ça deviendra le le centre
de l'innovation dans le dans l'énergie
en france par exemple
peut-être dans le cadre de la future
exposition universelle où le plateau de
saclay dans le cas du grand paris
pourrait être vraiment un très grand
démonstrateur d'écoquartier sur toutes
ces thématiques énergétique
hasard du calendrier la faculté des
sciences célèbre son demi siècle
l'année internationale de la lumière
voilà qui permet d'illuminer le gâteau
d'anniversaire avec cinq jours de
festivités des spectacles des concerts
ouverts à tous
notre équipe était présente le jour de
l'inauguration cet événement c'était
vraiment la lancée de la semaine sur les
50 ans de la faculté des sciences et les
74 du campus d'orsay
donc l'idée important pour nous en fait
de marquer le coup comme on dit de cet
événement d'abord d'un point de vue
historique parce que c'est quand même la
création de ce campus avec le cnrs de
gif et le cea de saclay donc on était
les trois pieds on va dire du futur
campus de saclay historiquement avec des
grands personnages comme les joliot
curie et puis de percer des messages
dans notre rôle et nos missions de
faculté des sciences et d'universités
paris sud donc aussi bien côté recherche
où on était vraiment très recherche
fondamentale on l'est toujours
et puis on évolue c'est vraiment une des
caractéristiques de la faculté des
sciences vers tout ce qui est appliqué
et les enjeux socio-économiques qui
aujourd'hui vont faire aussi l'enjeu de
paris saclay et puis sur les formations
avec des formations qu'on a connus
depuis 50 ans et la faculté des sciences
a vraiment su évoluer en accueillant le
plus grand nombre puisque ça a été la
démocratisation de l'enseignement et en
même temps en gardant la qualité de ses
diplômés de ces enseignements donc c'est
pour ça que il était important de fêter
ses 50 ans
j'ai connu ce campus bien avant qu'il
soit campus de l'université paris-sud
par la suite l'université paris sud a
été créé et bien évidemment ce campus
superbe et de très haut niveau a été un
des fleurons de cette université je
pense que ce campus est complètement
intégrée à ce qui se passe sur le
plateau de saclay et c'est même un
élément essentiel puisque c'est là que
se trouve un très grand nombre de notre
science fondamentale de notre physique
biologie de nos mathématiques
bref de tout ce qui a fait la faculté
des sciences d'orsay et qui va faire
aussi le prestige de la faculté de
l'université paris saclay comme il a
fait le prestige de l'université paris
sud bien entendu il va y avoir des
transformations
d'une part pour restructurer ce campus
mais aussi pour créer des logements
étudiants par exemple ou des bâtiments
qui vont créer une vie à l'intérieur du
campus qui fait que c'est un campus
moderne avec une intrication de
plusieurs activités
donc cet avenir s'intègre totalement
dans ce qui est visé pour l'université
paris saclay que ce soit sur le plateau
ou dans la vallée
retour à présent sur la journée
entrepreneuriat étudiant de l'université
paris saclay c'était la cinquième
édition
l'occasion pour les étudiants
entrepreneurs de présenter leur projet
ils étaient plus de 230 à participer à
la manifestation
un vrai succès pascal corbel
coordinateur du comité de pilotage de
peps pôles de l'entrepreneuriat
qu'étudiant paris saclay vous en dit
plus
c'est la journée entrepreneuriat
étudiant est un événement annuel qui est
organisé pour permettre aux étudiants et
aux jeunes diplômés mais surtout aux
étudiants de présenter leur projet
d'entreprise quel que soit leur stade
d'avancement est avant tout une journée
pour que se réalise des rencontres donc
ils peuvent trouver des partenaires
éventuellement des investisseurs ils
présentent leur projet qui sait
peut-être peuvent-ils aussi trouver des
clients
et puis comme ils se rencontrent entre
eux également ce format réseau des
étudiants entrepreneurs de paris saclay
l'une des difficultés pour les étudiants
entrepreneurs c'est de trouver le temps
pour travailler sur leur projet tout en
menant à bien leur étude
c'est pour ça qu'on a proposé le diplôme
entrepreneuriat étudiant et le statut
d'étudiant entrepreneurs qui leur
permettent notamment de travailler sur
leur projet là où il ferait un stage en
entreprise
il ya énormément de d'initiative un
plusieurs des établissements de
l'université paris saclay avait déjà
lancé des initiatives des incubateurs en
faveur de l'entrepreneuriat l'a donc
nous avons le pôle entrepreneuriat et
innovation paris saclay qui propose des
formations un appel à projets pré
maturation pour financer le lancement
des projets les pré-études nous avons un
environnement intéressant avec les
pépinières de la communauté
d'agglomération paris saclay la maison
de l'entreprise à saint quentin en
yvelines c'est vraiment un territoire
très très riches sans compter pour les
projets technologiques les laboratoires
que tous les établissements universités
mue du territoire
nous sommes une équipe de six étudiants
de l'est à paris tech qui menons un
projet autonome au cours de notre
dernière année d'études qui porte sur
l'implantation d'un réseau de transport
urbain par câble sur le plateau de
saclay nous avons commencer bien sûr par
une étude de marché
la contacter des entreprises privées
mais aussi des organismes publics les
localités les mairies les associations
et aussi paul vi qui développe le
transport sur le plateau de saclay le
but c'est pas uniquement de prendre
contact mais c'est aussi de se
rencontrer et d'essayer de deux proches
de prendre des mesures et des décisions
pour accélérer l'implantation du
téléphérique
c'est l'année internationale de la
lumière c'est aussi le printemps des
poètes avec la journée mondiale de la
poésie proclamé le 21 mars
les textes des auteurs célébrer toute
l'année ici dans ce lieu nous sommes à
la maison de la poésie de saint quentin
en yvelines
rencontre avec son directeur jacques
fournier là on est en plein printemps
des poètes enfin termine notre printemps
des poètes commencé le 4 mars on termine
le 29 mars donc c'est un programme qui
est principalement créé sur la
thématique de cette année du xviie
printemps des poètes c'est à dire la
surrection politique d'où la
présentation aujourd'hui du baron perché
donc ce fameux texte d'italo calvino qui
parle vraiment d'un véritable insurgés
d'un révolté qui a 12 ans décide de
grimper dans les arbres de ne plus
redescendre de toute sa vie
aum
avec jean laville
puis quelques mois seulement deux
étaient amis attaque maintenant de
sanctions s'accumulent et on écrit à
didier triste chapitre
voilà on a donc une programmation très
éclectique sur tout le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines depuis depuis
le début du mois ont investi le ciné 7
pour un hommage à prévert et des enfants
du paradis
on est allé dans les médiathèques on a
travaillé que la ferme de bel ébat on
travaille avec la ville de trappes
voilà donc toutes ces choses là font
partie de notre programme n'est ce
depuis la maison existe depuis 13 ans
quoi regarder le gros de cette maison
elle est inscrite sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines mais même au
delà puisque nous travaillons aussi avec
le conseil général pour un festival qui
a lieu en octobre tous les ans depuis
dix ans 11 ans maintenant mais qui nous
permet aussi d'investir les collèges et
travailler avec des bibliothèques sur
tout et toutes les communes qui veulent
bien travailler avec nous et donc nous
sommes ouverts nous à toute
collaboration d'autant que cette maison
est là elle est là vraiment pour pour
les habitants pour les gens
de saint quentin mais même au delà et je
considère moi que la poésie à sa place
partout donc le travail que nous menons
aussi par exemple avec un établissement
comme la maison de l'environnement des
sciences et du développement durable est
tout à fait cohérent c'est à dire que
intervenir dans une exposition comme
matisse hymne et présenter une rencontre
avec des écrivains pour qui les
mathématiques ou ont de l'importance
comme les oulipiens pour moi c'était
tout à fait logique et naturelle voilà
donc on a vraiment mission à être
présent partout parce que je considère
comme à la poésie à sa place partout
avant de nous quitter un coup d'oeil sur
notre agenda avec déjà la science break
biologie on ne présente plus le concept
trois chercheurs dix minutes
l'intervention chacun le programme
précis est consultable sur le site
science break point fr paris saclay vous
informe aussi à des travaux en cours
sachez que jusqu'à fin avril 2015 le ps
réalise des travaux au niveau du
boulevard bové du boulevard nord à
palaiseau ces chantiers implique la
modification des circulation automobile
et piétonne le déplacement d'arrêt de
bus
une signalétique a été mise en place
pour guider les usagers pour plus
d'information notre site pps point fr
et voilà c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
on se retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de paris saclay cv